president-elect joe biden is calling the
november jobs report quote
dire and says congress and president
trump must provide immediate relief
relief
for families and businesses but biden
says
whatever comes is just a down payment
correspondent peter ducey reporting from
wilmington delaware tonight
the president-elect knows he will
inherit an economy
affected by the pandemic the folks out
there aren't looking for a handout
they just need help he's pleased a
bipartisan group
of senators is reaching across the aisle
on a 900 billion dollar stimulus
proposal
if we act now now i mean now
we can begin to regain momentum but he
won't reveal what he's been telling
elected officials well it would be kind
of stupid for me to tell you what i did
wouldn't it
it'd be kind of hard to do it again
transition officials say
many cabinet announcements are coming
soon hope you have your coffee
and your spinach or whatever keeps you
going because it will be busy between
now and christmas
it'll be busy at the house oversight
committee too republicans there want to
know why california's secretary of state
alex padilla who could be appointed to
fill the vacant kamala harris senate
seat soon
gave a 35 million contract to a biden
linked firm
skdk knickerbocker to make voter
contacts
if he is in fact the person that
governor newsom
selects to replace kamala harris in the
senate then he's going to have to answer
this probably before the senate
ethics committee so we might as well
answer these questions now
this is clearly improper use of taxpayer
dollars
the transition team is still getting up
to speed on operation warp speed
there is no detailed plan that we've
seen anyway
as to how you get the vaccine out of
a container into an injection
syringe into somebody's arm fox news
asked the president-elect what happens
next do you think
seems to be mandatory no i don't think
it should be mandatory i wouldn't demand
to be mandatory but i would
do everything in my power just like i
don't think masks have to be made
mandatory nationwide
biden would not commit to picking a
person of color as
his secretary of defense or attorney
general but says his cabinet will be the
most
diverse ever and he's shrugging off
complaints about a lack of diversity in
the picks
so far from civil rights groups saying
it's those groups job
to push leaders for more diversity john
he also gave up on his campaign pledge
of a national mask mandate pretty
quickly too
peter ducey thanks so much